hi there steve kaufman here to talk
about language learning and to talk
about something that i think is quite
important
and that is focus
how do we learn to focus we need to
focus in language learning uh i googled
focus i found lots of articles about
things we can do to improve our focus we
can meditate or or you know how do we
push distractions out of our head and
stuff like that
but i would like to suggest a different
approach and that is in order to focus
when language learning and learning a
language
don't focus
diversify all right
before i get into explaining what i mean
and and and referring a little bit to my
own language learning uh habits
i want to refer to two basic concepts
that at least i believe are important to
how the brain learns
the first comes from this book by
manfred spitzer
s-p-i-t-z-e-r a german neuroscientist
and this is a very interesting book
about learning you can google you can
find it on amazon and one of the things
he said in there that has stuck with me
is that first of all he explains how
obviously the brain learns through
experience by being exposed to
different things in life including
language
but that the brain requires
both repetition and novelty new things
in order to stay focused in order to
learn
if it just has repetition after a while
it learns less and less
robert bjork who is a professor of
psychology at the university of
california in los angeles
deals with the same subject from a
different perspective
and you can find his videos on youtube b
j o r k robert bjork
and his
main you know contribution at least to
my understanding of how we learn is this
concept of interleaving
that we are better off to
interleave to not try to
block learn something but rather to
learn this and then go and learn that
then come back to the first thing again
and that this strengthens our ability to
remember
okay so
novelty as well as repetition and
interleaving so how do we apply this to
language learning well if i look at my
own particular case
arabic so i have
been spending a lot of time with our
many stories at link i've listened to
some of them 30 40 50 times read them
many many times there's 60 stories
i have uploaded essie mill and i've gone
through a number of to those stories a
number of times i've done the
manual
modern
which is also uploaded to link
and then recently i started looking at
harrops
in fact
and i've got the audio for harp so i've
been listening to the audio for arabs i
even went to the defense language
institute site where you can find a lot
of old courses and there's one on arabic
i mean absolute brain dead repetition i
don't know how people could stay
in a full-time course like that but
again it's another kind of learning and
every time that you discover
words or
structures of the language that you have
perhaps learned before and forgotten and
then you find them again somewhere else
it's sort of a bit of repetition and yet
a bit of novelty there's a tremendous
sense of satisfaction in discovering
these things in a different context
so by not focusing just on one textbook
i find that i'm covering the same
material in different textbooks
and when i switch to another textbook
and then switch back to our source book
and switch back to the first one
i feel a great sense of satisfaction
whereas if i continually stay with the
same material after a while my
enthusiasm my interest
that sense of novelty is no longer there
and therefore my ability to focus
diminishes so
diversifying
the material you use
the approaches you use the things you do
actually improves your ability to focus
i could even take it a little further by
saying that
when i listen
i have to be doing something else doing
the dishes i mean that defense language
institute material is so brain dead that
i was doing it while taking inventory of
something at home for two hours but it
was kind of going in the background and
i pick it up because it's so repetitious
i i couldn't do that with something that
i had to try to really understand
but
when i listen i can't sit down
and deliberately try to focus on
listening
i have to be washing the dishes working
out doing something else
if i just sit there and try to focus on
what i'm listening to
i lose focus i can't do it now maybe
that's just me
so actually some degree of multitasking
now you got to be careful what you're
doing but certainly driving doing the
dishes working out walking running these
are all things that i can do while
listening
so
refreshing things diversifying into
other things then coming back to what
you were doing before
all of that helps me focus
and i think this applies to other
subjects it may not apply to you know i
don't know science maybe where you have
to learn
you know the basics and then you build
on that and build on that whereas
language is not really like that you're
getting it in different
forms from different sources and certain
things are sucking into place and other
things take longer to sock into place
and by exposing yourself to the language
in different situations it starts to
become
a part of you but i think a lot of um
you know history for example is like
that or the humanities is like that uh i
think uh it's important if you're
learning history to read three or four
books on the same
subject rather than trying to focus on
learning the one textbook i mean getting
back to language learning
typically in our school system there is
a textbook there is a curriculum the
kids are taught that this is what you
have to learn
they're reluctant to stray from the
curriculum
and yet the results are very poor at
least in in the canadian system the you
know english speaking school kids don't
learn to speak french very well even
though they stay with the curriculum
maybe
in our schools as i've said before we
should just allow kids to explore and
what we should measure
rather than performance on tests is how
many words have they read in the
language how many hours have they
listened to the language
if they're using link how many words
have they saved you know any of this
measurement of their activity
you know
diversified activities spread out over
different types of material that they
find interesting
so that they are achieving some
repetition in the language but at the
same time they are at least provided
some degree of novelty
so
you know
there are many distractions today
in learning a language language learning
has become much more efficient because
we can do it on our our you know
portable
tablets or
smartphones and so forth or on the
internet but of course those are also
places where there are lots of
distractions
and when we tend to want to
go off
check our twitter feed is when our
interest in the language is kind of
sagging so therefore in order to
better focus
stray a bit within
the language you're learning
in order to stay focused
i'm not going to address today the issue
of studying another language i have
stayed focused on arabic for the last
six seven months and
i may stray into farsi when we get farsi
many stories up at link and that seems
to be delayed and delayed
but it's still within the sort of arabic
writing system we'll see what happens
but
i i i seriously recommend that in order
to be better at staying focused
try to diversify what you're doing you
may find that you are more focused
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you